game one and let us begin
so d4 one sec
[Music]
okay so d4
um let's go with a kings indian 1500
well i like that look yeah yeah i i need
to shave i agree
you're hilarious aquila your you're like
so funny right now
i'm honestly i'm laughing really really
hard man
okay so we're gonna play the king's
indian and let's see
how curious chimpanzee handles it so we
castle this is all very standard
thank you freezy sub for the prime okay
so
uh curious plays the london
system approach to the king's indian
which is very much
a legitimate line we're now going to
play d6
and as i've explained
several times in the king's indian black
has two main pawn breaks
the most traditional pawn break is e5
and the whole idea of putting the bishop
on f4
is that you make it a lot more difficult
for black to play e5 that should be
obvious to people
but when you play bishop f4 you
allow black to execute another pawn
break
and that other pawn break becomes quite
a bit stronger
when the bishop is outside of the pawn
chain what other pawn break am i talking
about
how else can we control part of the
center
and we're gonna do that here because we
haven't done much of that yeah the move
is c5 so
you lose some of the how should i put it
the king's indian ness of this line
thank you vp
indeed indeed the king's indian is going
to be curious about some of the
is going to be curious about who's
pounding the king's in the chimpanzee is
going to be curious if i was pounding
him
so the king's indian is going to be
curious think of banidad
okay what i was going to say is
exclam claim what does that mean
i don't understand what's what's
happening
yeah anyways so it's more in the spirit
of the king's indian to play e5 but c5
is also fine now
do we take on d4 is there any need for
us to take on d4
and if not what would be a good move
here
okay we we're focused on the game here
yeah there's no need just knight c6 we
just develop our knight
there's absolutely no need for us to
whoops penguin
is playing first oh interesting okay
there's absolutely no need for us to
oh you have to type claim that's the
neo19101 with five subs exactly so
knight c6
and now we can develop our bishop to g4
very important that
and thank you yeah boy dm thank you dio
there's absolutely no need to take on d4
that would actually give up part of the
center
so we're going to play bishop g4
all right don't think
claim claim works like that yeah so
now white goes h3 and
we have to yeah i'm kind of distracted
by this
claim thing hard for me to to focus on
explaining
so basically we have to decide whether
we take on f3 or not now bishop h5 is
out out of the question because that
that loses the bishop to g4 but
um bishop takes f3 might seem like a bad
idea to people why are we moving the
bishop twice what do we accomplish
with this trade what is it exactly that
we
accomplish with this trade because it
seems that we actually just make white's
bishops stronger
but this trade accomplishes
um this trade actually accomplishes
something very specific yes we we
removed the protection on d4
holy smokes 5g ramen bowl with 10 subs
oh my god
damn girl damn okay so the d4 pawn has
been weakened thank you so much for the
10 gifts it subs
i'll thank everyone properly after the
game how do we pressure that pawn
we now need to pressure the d4 pawn with
a move that brings another piece out of
the game there is a very simple way to
do that
um yeah so i'll talk about d5 after the
game and in fact maybe
curious we'll play d5 yeah the move is
queen b6
so e5 would be a very weakening move we
would weaken the d5
square so queen b6 we are now
threatening to take the pawn
and what's the big deal here why is it
that we are doing all of this we
actually want him to play d5
we actually want him to play d5 and if
he plays d5 i'll explain why
yes he does what is the effect of the
move d5 the effect of this move
is that this bishop is now open and that
is a very serious bishop it is
uncontested on the long diagonal
the other thing that happens as a
consequence of d5
is that the c4 pawn well a pawn chain is
created
and you guys already know that when a
pawn chain is created you got to think
about attacking the base of the pawn
chain
can we attack the base of the pawn chain
so knight e5 would allow him to take
on e5 and we would have to slightly ruin
our pawn structure but
we can do the same thing from a5
and the the good thing about this move
why i like this move from an
illustrative standpoint is that
it puts the knight on on a rim the
knight is on a corner
and people might be looking at this and
saying well isn't this night bad knights
on the rim are grim
but when you reach the level of like
1600 plus you you need to be able to
violate some of these opening prints
some of these general principles
otherwise
you'll be completely constrained um you
won't be able to make any move because
it violates some sort of obscure
principle now
this bishop is really opened up so let's
move the knight back
to open up the diagonal for the bishop
and pressure the knight
curious is playing really really well i
have to say but now we have an
interesting plan yeah now we go queen b4
to attack the knight again so the bishop
is now cooperating with the queen
let's see what um what white does here
and the knight doesn't have that many
good squares there's another idea that
queen before has
there's another idea that queen before
has
queen d2 is very good and the other idea
that it has again thinking about
attacking the c4 pawn
it's yeah so we want to go b5 but if we
go b5 right now he's going to take the
pawn
so we can prepare b5 with the move a6
we can prepare b5 with the move a6 very
simple and once we play b5 we start
getting
a lot of play on that queen side and
it's bore 30 thank you for the prime
this is more of a bononi that's why i
like to play e5 rather than
rather than c5 because this is more of a
benoni esque position but it's not like
this is that hard to understand the
ideas are pretty straightforward
all right
can i teach you what a vertical
asymptote is i mean i can
but this is a chess speed run
yeah similar ideas you know in the
king's indian you also see
some of these some of these concepts
okay so he's taken on b5 we've taken
back sorry for the i know
some people don't like me to pre-move
but a takes b5 is what we did
and um okay so when a trade like this
happens we need to understand
the immediate effects of the trade what
has changed as a consequence
of this trait now first thing is why no
longer has the pawn chain so we need to
look at this pawn and say okay the d5
pawn is kind of flimsy
the second thing that has happened as a
result of the pawn chain of the
pontrait is that the a file has opened
well what lies on the a4 ah
there's an a2 pawn that lies on the a
file oh how can we exploit that a2 but
we have a rook on a
we just need to get this knight out of
a5 but we don't want to do that just yet
because he wants to take the queen and
open up the c file we don't want to
allow that
we have two approaches here we can
actually trade queens
but um what we can also do is go queen
to a3
and prepare to move the knight back to
b7 but
okay let me think yeah both are both are
super tempting but let's go queen a3 i
know people like me to keep the queens
on the board sometimes
now we are ready to play knight b7 and
increase the pressure dial on the a2
pawn
knight b7 is black sensitive yeah so
once we put the knight on b7 we're gonna
have to take care of this knight
somehow the knight will be kind of
passive
but um as i always claim and you guys
know this by now not every one of your
pieces needs to be
you know curing covet it's okay to have
some pieces temporarily on
awkward positions if you know that
you're going to improve them later
hmm
bishop b2 that's a no chimpanzee is
playing very well
so he's attacking the pawn we need to
defend it
who can propose a way to defend the pawn
what would be a a way that is sort of
conducive also to the
general direction that we are playing
and we are playing on the queen side
so it would be a nice thing if we could
bring pieces
into the queen side and simultaneously
depend upon i like to move rook f to b8
because now we are accumulating a lot of
pieces on the queen side
which is a little bit unusual because
most games in the speedrun at some point
we've been attacking the king
but attacks on the other side of the
board
work in much the same way that an attack
on the king
works right you need to bring pieces in
you need to identify weaknesses that you
are attacking when you're attacking
the king then by definition the main
weakness is the king
but here you need to do the additional
work of identifying specific targets
that you can
you can pile up on we've already
identified a target that target is the
is the a2 pawn okay so he's attacking
b5 and we need to be careful our queen
we need to make sure our queen doesn't
get trapped we have a very nice move
here
which also solves the problem of this
knight being a little bit passive
and it also drives more pieces into the
queen side and it starts putting that
very concrete pressure on his position
well b4 knight b5
is kind of annoying the move is c4
yes c4 what this does is it targets the
b3 pawn
a and b if he takes
what should we take with what should we
take with
well actually uh either is fine i mean i
like taking with the knight because that
simultaneously opens up that
simultaneously opens up
the the um the a file right so we
actually solve the problem of the a5 we
could have also taken with the pawn
though that was
that would have been fine
okay so
let's see how chimpanzee chooses to
defend here he takes we take now
not only is the a file open but also the
b
file is open so we are threatening to
move rook to b2 you can see how much
pressure
white is under here and none of what
we've done so far has anything to do
with white's king
so what this shows is um you don't
always have to orient yourself toward
a king side attack you can attack your
opponent's queen side
uh and and you can do that with equal
effectiveness
okay yeah this is starting to look very
very
very very dubious
or rook b1 would drop the knight
okay now we need to be very patient
very very patient some people might be
attracted to the move bishop take c3
but look at the bigger picture here the
bishop is our
one of our main attacking pieces we
don't want to give it up yet
what we want to do is now bring pieces
into the attack we need to identify
pieces that can be improved and as you
guys are indicating this night of course
was just
lounging around on d7 we can slam it on
to b3 onto d3 and then we're going to
start looking for ways to win material
thank you for the prime
i mean look at how all of our pieces are
beautifully coordinated it's like every
one of our pieces is participating now
in the queen side attack
which tells my intuition that we're very
soon going to have to start looking for
ways to to to transform that advantage
into something more concrete
so which means looking for tactics
okay and i already see a couple of
possibilities like what specifically do
i notice here well the knight on c3 is
very v
is very flimsy so there might be tactics
in relation to
taking well if we take the knight on c3
that would be a bad move
rook b1 is a great move by chimpanzee
because bishop takes c3 would allow rook
takes b8
check and then y would recapture on c3
so let's be very careful about those
kinds of moves
and um we can just ignore this okay
that's another thing
i've been harping on quite a for quite a
long time now
when your opponent offers a trade uh
people
generally think well i have to do
something about it but you really don't
in many cases we can let him be the one
to take our rook then we get control of
the b
file so that's perfectly good
okay so already white is under
insurmountable amount of pressure
chimpanzee defending extremely well
though and not making it easy for me at
all
and um depending on where he goes
i already have several pretty cool ideas
here
okay yeah i just had some some good food
okay so i'm looking now i'm actually
thinking about
how we can go about continuing the
pressure c
amg thank you for the five gifted
wow appreciate it appreciate it very
much
okay my coffee machine just blipped but
i wasn't making any
coffees thanks again i'm gonna have to
check that out 92 is a good move
92 is a very good move because he's
getting the knight out of the danger
zone and he's attacking
he's attacking the c4 pawn so let's
defend that pawn
now we already need to figure out how
we're actually going to win this game
and the let me think
so the way that i want to defend it we
want to defend the pawn in a way that
continues the pressure on his position
it's a hard thing for me to formulate
but a very good move so knight p2 would
not be good and let me explain that
after the game i actually think knight
p2 we're going to go queen to a4
i didn't like knight b2 and i will
explain the logic behind that after the
game
so we'll see
yeah queen a4 also puts the brook under
some pressure so that's that's the
reason i like queen a4
we are now threatening of course to
check on b1 and then
f2 is going to fall i mean that position
is going to be
terrible terrible for white so we'll see
how he
tries to defend this but this is
essentially over
c5 was fine no queen c5 was good you
could have targeted this one too
okay now knight c1 is also really good
um let me think
hmm okay let's go rook b1 let's pin
yeah there's a really really cool line
here there's a very very pretty line
that that was what i was calculating the
reason i didn't play this immediately a
rook b1 pins the knight
white has a really interesting resource
okay king h2 is is a fantastic move
so now we can essentially transform the
advantage so
it would be very nice if we could go c3
c3 uh would be a great move
but unfortunately that would blunder the
knight so can we
make a preliminary move and then play c3
i mean can we
can we do something with this knight and
this is the concept of transforming the
advantage
from a logical perspective this move
might seem weird because the knight was
really
beautiful but we are you know we're
breaking the eggs to make the omelet we
are taking we're giving away the knight
so that we can play c3 and the queen is
over extended
queen is making contact with f4 it's
also making contact with the rook
white's queen cannot move anywhere to
keep both of these things under control
in fact
we are winning not only upon we are
winning actually more than upon
okay so let's see what he does
yes so now a lot of people would
immediately grab this pawn
but when you have a capture like this
you always need to find the best
execution for something you just don't
want to rush in a situation like this
because the game-winning tactic can
present itself in any position
yeah rook takes c1 you guys already see
if you feel like
just don't rush you already have a much
better chance of seeing that you can
take on c1
setting up a fork and you're going to be
a piece up in the end and this pawn is
going to be
on the path to promotion but nonetheless
a very very good game by curious
who who put up a terrific fight good
game
now okay so it was a king's indian
right so as i explained the king's
indian there are two main
oh it was announced yes tata steel so
you already know hamad
so on a different on a separate note
i will be and i i didn't want to
announce this before because it wasn't
official but seems like it's official
flying puppy dog one thank you for the
five gifted subs
short but sweet is this stream thank you
but
i will be doing i have the great honor
of doing the first half of the tata
steel
over the board classical tournament
which will be beginning in
i believe exactly one week from now i
will be doing
the first half of the official
commentary with co-commentator fiona
fiona stale and tony
in the second half will be done by my
partner in crime robert hess
so robert and sophie will be covering
the second half it's it's probably the
biggest tournament i've i'm not going to
vacancy
i will be doing it from home um no i
will not be in person i will be
commentating from
from charlotte but the tournament itself
will be
played over the board and my
co-commentator will be in waikanse
um no the tournament is not virtual but
i will be commentating from home
and um basically
it's you know i've never had an
opportunity to commentate
a tournament that is this prestigious in
this
uh of this stature i'm super excited at
this opportunity i'm gonna try to
do the very best that i can the rounds
begin at eight a.m
eastern so i will be alerting my 18
friends who have my number to
call me at respective times
but yeah it's going to be an amazing
tournament i'm going to have to remake
my schedule so that i
i'm fully alert and energetic it's a big
opportunity
it's a huge honor but anyways just
wanted to put that out there so that'll
be happening
a week from now i'll be putting out more
updates closer to the actual date of the
first round
back to the game um there's e5
and there is c5 thank you cs window the
problem with
e5 is that right now it blunders upon
and it's actually not that easy to
prepare e5 you can you can go knight bd7
and then you can go rookie eight
but the other problem is that if you go
rookie a and then you go e5
it looks like the coast is clear but
this actually also blunders upon
why who can tell me why this also
does not properly execute e5 what does
white have here
what does white have here yeah so he
takes
and then we notice that the d file is
open
and then we take again and the rook is
overloaded that's a classic
trope in the king's indian the rook
being overloaded like this
we take the queen force the rook out and
now bishop takes the five wins upon
so long story short it's possible whoops
sorry
long story short it is possible to
prepare e5 but not easy c5 is much
easier
okay so c5 uh bishop e2 we develop our
knight and a lot of people were looking
at this and saying wait a second what
happens if white plays d5
this is one of the main ideas in some
lines of the king's indian where the
knight actually goes to a5
we saw something like this in the game i
put my knight here to attack the pawn
here the knight doesn't actually
threaten to capture the pawn
so it might seem absolutely senseless
but in combination with a particular
plan
the knight is often put on a5 in order
to pressure c4 and that plan is of
course a6 and b5
you are trying to get this pawn break to
work in order to ruin
white's pawn chain and get a lot of
queen side play
nobody said it's easy to prepare b5 and
often the pawn is sacrificed you will
see
in many king's indian lines uh a sort of
bangko like flavor to the position where
you literally just go b5 and you do that
in order to open the b
file and uh if any of you have played
the benko gambit
all of this would be very familiar this
is like a good benko gavin because you
already have
a lot of pieces that are aimed at the
queen side
have i had any games where i do
something very similar and i sacrifice
upon a b5 i've had plenty i've had
several games where
i really enjoy as you guys can imagine
this particular line where you sacrifice
upon and you get a lot of play
uh even from a practical perspective it
can be much easier to play this with
with black than with white because black
has this super
natural attack going on um
let me see so let me show you one of
these games from a couple years back
okay perfect so we already have
everything set up here so this game from
the world youth under 13
i was playing black it was a different
line of the king's indian this one was
the same-ish
but here you can see that i played c5
and here i put my knight on e5 because i
could
but here's b5 here's the pawn sacrifice
and the play look at me look at how
simple the play is just bishop a6 queen
a volga gambit as they say in russian
rook ft1 i take i get my knight to c4 i
mean every piece literally just comes in
and i just crushed him i mean i won the
pawn back and actually you can see the
similarity between this game and my game
against
chimpanzee like the c pawn is what
ultimately decided
the game the sea pawn is what ultimately
decided the game
so this is a super common idea if you
play the kings indian you should always
keep in mind
this particular idea
um and back to the game
so bishop g4 we soften up
the d4 pawn and now we play queen b6
this is probably not
amazing for black but it's it's a pretty
thematic idea so i decided to play it
now we kind of compel white to do
something with the d-pawn and again we
go 95
we get the knight out to open up the
bishop we go queen b4 to pressure the
knight
and and then we prepare b5 so we did all
of this in the game after queen b6 what
if he plays knight a4
um knight e4 we can that's probably not
a bad move
but maybe we can reposition the queen on
a5 and now the knight becomes awkward
so yes it's true we're no longer
attacking the pawn but now the knight is
awkward
um no h18 i this was under 18.
so something like this um after queen
before i already think black gets pretty
big pressure so i'm not sure exactly
where your decisive mistake was
my guess is let me think for a second
okay i think somewhere here white should
have played in a way
to make a6b5 more difficult so here's
one
thing i could propose like you can go
queen c2
and then rook c1 the fact that you put
your queen on d2 made it a little bit
harder for you
to move the knight maybe drop the bishop
back to e2
maybe drop the bishop back to e2
discourage black from playing b5
so something like that would have been
would have been an interesting try
because once i go b5 the pressure on
white's position becomes
extremely strong queen a3 rook b8 and
everything here is supernatural c4
a lot of people wanted b4 but this also
weakened some of these light squares and
knight b5
almost traps the queen black has only
the b2 square
and now white can excommunicate the
queen from there that's definitely not
what
black wants so be very careful about
these tempting moves that threaten an
opponent's piece
c4 instead is much better yeah so it
takes
knight c5 we get the knight into d3 you
can see some of the similarities between
this game and the game i played now
queen a4 last thing
uh yes so when i'm back later tonight
i will try to do the parham parham games
yeah there's ghosts if i'm back later
tonight
now um why did i play queenie for a lot
of people wanted knight b2 thank you
jonathan for the 500 bits
really appreciate it okay
knight p2 why what attracts people to
this move could somebody explain to me
somebody who proposed mp2 what is it
that you like about this move
and hopefully that'll help me a chance
to give me a chance to better explain
what i don't like about it
yeah but you still can't push the pawn
that's the thing uh because the knight
is controlling
that square the what i think attracts
people is that it attacks the pawn
right i get it so so here's the thing
um you want to be very careful about
putting a knight on v2 because that's
the only thing the knight is doing the
knight is now not doing anything other
than defending the pawn
it's not a great idea to tie your pieces
down like this when we played queen a4
it is true that the queen is defending
the pawn but that's not the only thing
the queen is doing
queen is also pressuring the rook it's
just involved in the queen side
knight on b2 is otherwise very awkward
and a2
is not the prize that i'm going for here
well i can go knight c3
and if you just abandon everything and
you take on a2
that's tunnel vision at a higher level
you've won upon congratulations
but you've given up your bishop you've
weakened your king and now white gets
all this counter play
and your pieces are sort of stranded on
the upper quadrant of the board where
they're not doing anything
sorry and also finally the knight on d3
is just a huge beast
um the knight is a beast it's it's
controlling f2 it's pressuring f2
so you want to be careful about moves
like these if that makes sense
so queen a4 rook b1
and now of course knight takes f4 is the
decisive move we cannot play c3
because that gives up the knight so we
do ultimately give up the knight
uh but we do that in the service of a
greater good so to speak
c3 and rook takes c1 could you say
something about why you waited with rook
you want to move 25
um if we gave a check immediately
and then took on f2 then he had rook
takes
c4 and he gets this evil there is one
line i wanted to show
which is after rook b1 he had a crazy
resource
queen takes d3 okay what's the point of
this and why does it not work for extra
credit why does it not work this comes
very close to winning the game for white
uh why does it come close to winning the
game
and what is black's reputation this i
had to see when i played
uh rogue b1 rook c8 check that's not
mate
but what is mate is bishop h6 very
common
tactical idea this creates the seemingly
unstoppable threat of rook takes f8
checkmate
uh but there is a defense and rook takes
c1 track distracts the rook from c8
and then we can take the bishop on h6 so
without this move black is losing i
believe because you can give a check on
d1
and now you literally have no more good
checks so
there is no defense that rook takes that
fake checkmate rook takes c1 is
absolutely obligatory good game trump
that was uh very well played not
certainly not easy for me
and i think an instructive game in terms
of playing like a banco gambit in the
king's indian okay
any questions thank you scoma for the
prime
quite edifying indeed glad to hear that
all right we got time for for one more
game
um or maybe not even one more game yeah
i i
8 30 i have to do something let's play
akila because he normally plays
fast um yeah crazy tournament tomorrow
and let's play e4
okay so c5 okay we we've played the c3
sicilian
almost exclusively this time let's go
for an open sicilian the main line
let's go with d4 he plays the e6 line
which is the khan
or the powelson or the taimanov okay so
knight c6 this is the introduction to
the taimanov
and um there's nothing white there's
many moves that white has here there's
knight p5 but let's play it simple let's
just develop our knight
and generally speaking queen c7 is the
move or a6 yeah
now again white has a gazillion
different setups
in the taemon of or in these lines
literally a gazillion i mean you can
develop the bishop wherever you want you
can go here here
here i personally like fianchettoing the
bishop
because what you're going to see is that
the fiance bishop
does not it's out of the way
and it exerts a lot of pressure on the
center so i like being getting my bishop
in these lines that's just a personal
choice
that is certainly not objectively the
best line nor is it a bad line it's just
one of the many lines available to us
hello yeah so bishop g2
fianchettoing the bishop and often yeah
97 is very typical often what black does
is he takes on
on d4 and replaces one night with the
other knight okay so we castle i'm not
explaining the most because i'm just
developing my pieces
just like in any other opening just like
in any other opening
okay quincy sub now we need to start
um probing the position we need to make
a plan
yes that's right musical mike now
basically we have several pieces that
are not
developed that we can deploy the first
is the bishop the second is the rook on
f1 could be repositioned to e1
in order to well obviously in order to
x-ray black's king that's always a good
idea in the situation
but um let's let's decide what to do
with this bishop
now bishop e3 is well first of all
bishop f4
runs into knight takes d4 and e5
i actually don't like bishop b3 that
much
first of all because there is a better
prospect for the bishop second of all
because bishop
bishop is not really doing all that much
on e3 it's just sort of developed
and i believe that if we find an
alternate arrangement for the bishop
it's going to be doing quite a bit more
what am i talking about here bishop g5
is also not
it because black can just chase the
bishop away with h6
now remember that when you're not sure
about where to develop a piece right
let's say you're in a situation
you're not well bishop d2 blunders that
blunders the knight uh you're not sure
about where to develop the bishop
so you know what one alternative is not
to develop it
okay bishop f4 guy's already explained
bishop f4 runs into a fork knight takes
d4 and e5
people are forgetting that there is
something we can do with the bishop
that's not developing it on this day a
fiance
fianchettoing bishops we fianced one why
not the other
yes it takes two moves instead of one
big deal okay we've developed all of our
other pieces
so okay and i'm about to show you guys
why it's very sexy to fianchetto the
bishop because we have an even sexier
move here that already basically wins
the game
i expected akilah to do this and that's
part of the reason why i fianchetto now
how do i see this
bishop on g7 first thing i see it is
undefended
the bishop is undefended which means if
both knights were gone from these
squares
then the bishops would be in a standoff
that already
that already implies that there might be
some sort of a discovery
that may help the knight gets off the
get off the board fast
knight takes c6 is the tempting move but
there is an even better execution of
this
yeah but we don't want to sacrifice one
of the knights we don't want to
sacrifice both knights we want to if we
sacrificing it
it's good to sacrifice only one of the
knights yes knight db5
because we also exploit the positioning
of black's queen
one second
um okay so an itv5 right that is a very
cool move but the logic behind it should
be perfectly clear guys
we are repositioning one of our knights
we are moving it off of the diagonal
we are sacrificing it but after a takes
b5 knight takes b5
because of the attack on black's queen
black has to attend to that
which means that we are going to then
take the other bishop and attack black
stroke
completely disru i mean the king is just
demolished there and and black has just
lost
it does it matter in which order it
actually kind of does
because if we had moved the other knight
to b5 then the
black could have rejected the sacrifice
and gone with this queen
here but even that's lost here if he
does that then we can take on d6 that
was
the main reason why i moved this knight
okay
now we take the bishop by the way um
one sec
if we take on d6 or if we try to be
fancy then the problem is king f8 comes
and uh king f8 comes and and the king
defends
the bishop so we we can't do that we
instead take on g7 but this is perfectly
good enough we attack the rook
we take the pawn and his entire position
is absolutely destroyed here
we can take another pawn if we want to
but i actually wouldn't
i wouldn't take this pun
one second sorry give me a moment
okay so i would not take on f7 because
after king c7 we get into a funny
situation
where i have to trade queens and i don't
want to trade queens i want to checkmate
him so let's drop the bishop back to f6
we're already two pawns up
there's no pressing need to take a third
pawn although we could we could even
trade queens there's nothing wrong with
that
but with the queens on the board it's
going to be easier to complete the
attack now
all we need to do is bring pieces oops
god
skype call keep scaring me we need to
bring pieces into the game
one sec
okay we need to bring pieces into the
game
and and of course the d file is the most
natural avenue
to black's king so we are going to
double on that d file and then we're
going to look for discoveries
that involve moving the knight away
okay
one keeping the other rook there to
attack uh sorry to protect a2 and now
we're already looking for ways to move
the knight away knight b5
check comes to mind and then maybe
moving the queen away and attacking
black's queen
the og and keto bishop isn't doing
anything yeah but
uh it often does in these positions i
was thinking also about playing e5 and
opening it up queen d3 to triple is
fine but we don't need to triple like we
already have you know there's a russian
expression
basically killing an ant with a
cannonball
um and i my you know i had a friend who
would always use that my coach would
always use that
and um the point is it's like
if you're solving a quadratic equation
that you can factor with the quadra with
the uh quadratic formula that's a good
example of
um shooting ants with a cannonball like
you just don't need to use such a
such heavy weaponry doubling is good
enough
low press though thank you so knight b5
check
and now we can see that the rook x-rays
black screen through the lens of white
screen so if we move white's queen away
black's queen is going to be hanging
where should we move white's queen where
should we move white's queen
e3 check and actually we won't even
necessarily need to take black screen we
might just give checkmate here
okay
okay so the king on b5 is already toast
we actually don't need to take the queen
we'll be able to checkmate the king
without it
the king has only one path to escaping
back and that is to a6
so the move a4 is fine that does win
but a4 allows the king to escape back to
a6 let's play bishop f1
drawing the king further outward there's
gonna be some sort of a nice mate
okay there's a very simple oh there's
there's bishop c3 check but there is a
checkmate in two moves
there's a check made in two moves uh
simple mate
simple mate
yeah check b5 is forced
and then queen takes b5 because of that
bishop that that og
fiance bishop you spoke too soon my
friend i'd say it's doing something
it's participating in the checkmate so
the bishop does redeem itself but
ironically it redeems itself by
moving back to f1 good game good game um
aquila and yeah that move bishop g7 just
killed you
so yeah so this is like a key early
position
this is a key early position and i think
i've sort of bishop e3 is
by no means is it a mistake there's also
this nasty idea by the way of 95 knight
c4
and so often the bishop has to move back
to c1
but fiend ketone is just a much better
spot for the bishop now you would have
to be careful here noticing
the x-ray between the queen and the
knight so
but black has no way to exploit that if
black moves the knight away then then
you fee and keto fly takes the knight
then the queen takes the knight and
simultaneously defends the other knight
so uh g6 is is bad now how should black
play this position
i think you should take on d4 and go
knight c6 that's actually the main idea
of knight ge7 and the sicilian is to
replace one knight with the other knight
and then you don't have to fianchetto
your bishop you can go bishop e7 and
castle
[Music]